you have this one life to live and you
can either choose to be a spectator and
follow other people's awesome lives
or get out there and do the work that it
takes every single day
to better your life and better the lives
of others in the process
which will you choose
hey everyone welcome to yessi tv where
we talk about minimalism as more than
just decluttering
physical items from your life today's
video is specifically requested and i
hope that it will be beneficial to those
of you
who have seen some of my other videos on
digital minimalism such as
why i quit social media or how to break
your phone addiction
but it's for those of you who have
either quit or intend to and want to but
just can't help but keep coming back i
have a disclaimer before we
begin though i found out through a
couple viewers on some of my previous
videos that youtube is actually
considered social media
so upfront i apologize for having given
any misinformation
i did not know that youtube was
considered social media
but to that person who commented that i
be
beat needed to talk about how youtube
can be bad and cause depression and
anxiety
to you i say i am not the person to talk
about that because youtube has made a
positive impact in my life
youtube has allowed me to stalk people
like oprah tony robbins dave ramsey
basically i can learn from a lot of
people that i don't even have to know
in person and to the mommy youtubers you
saved my life when i was a new mom
so youtube has been beneficial for me
and i hope that what we talk about here
is beneficial in some sort of way
so just now so that we're all on the
same page that i am talking about
websites like facebook instagram twitter
those kinds of websites
not youtube all that being said on to
what you came here for
okay so you're sitting on your couch
you've quit social media you have your
reasons for why you did it
and you're thinking of opening these
apps again because
you just don't know what to do with
yourself guys this is withdrawal
having worked in an icu for a few years
i know that the first few days to weeks
of a withdrawal from alcohol or drugs
are crucial and can actually be
life-threatening okay
you're not going to die from not
checking websites like facebook
but your brain doesn't know the
difference it's used to that dopamine
spike that feeling of reward when you
check it
so it wants you to stop being
uncomfortable and do what makes it feel
good your brain is designed to save you
from saber-toothed tigers and any sign
of danger
this is why it's so darn difficult to do
the little things you know you should be
doing
such as finishing that assignment that
you have to or
getting up at 5am to finish that youtube
video
so tip number one is know your triggers
and have barriers for them
some of you mentioned triggers in the
comments such as fear of missing out
or boredom and first of all it's great
that you know what these temptations are
for you because
that way you can know what to attack to
make it harder to go back in the first
place
a few things that you can try for this
are to actually delete the accounts
instead of just unfollowing or
unsubscribing
this makes it a little bit harder to
actually go back but there are actually
apps out there that can help you stop
using these sorts of apps and accounts
such as
stay on task break free and what was the
other one off time
i've never actually used these apps
myself so i'm not telling you to use
these specific
ones but just know that these apps are
out there if you feel like the urge is
too strong to bear
next thing i would recommend for you is
to focus on
day by day instead of this long period
of time
don't tell yourself i'm going to quit
social media for a month or for a year
that's too stressful tell yourself today
i'm going to choose
to spend time with my family instead or
today
i'm going to work on that project that
i've been putting off for
a while today i'm going to focus on
improving myself
make the decision each day tip number
two is set goals for yourself
it's hard to find motivation for
something when you don't know why you're
doing it in the first place or where you
want to be in the future
since adopting a more minimalist
lifestyle one of the things that i love
to do is to set goals for myself
and i actually began by asking myself
where do i want to see myself in five to
ten years from now
i actually write out my goals on a
notebook and i have social goals health
goals financial goals and spiritual
goals
at the beginning of the year i write
down a list of major big goals that i
want to accomplish
and then i kind of break it down to make
it easier for myself to actually
get to those goals by setting monthly
and sometimes weekly goals
that i can keep tracking this helps me
to keep motivated and it gives me an
idea of
where i want to be in life and how to
actually get there
this way i feel like i'm actually
working towards something instead of
just
doing for the sake of doing or living
for the sake of living
so if you quit social media don't just
do it just because
ask yourself now what and set goals for
yourself
tip number three is strengthen your
relationships
in two months i will actually be on six
years now without social media
but one of the things that helped me a
lot during that time was that i was
trying to overcome a battle with social
anxiety
so i was intentionally trying to develop
stronger relationships with more
positive people
i intentionally made the purpose of
calling people and it started to call
people more often
and for someone with social anxiety this
was so extremely difficult
because it's not like when you're
sending a text or you're typing on a
computer
and you actually get to think about what
you're going to say before you say it
at the time i was also very involved in
my church and participating in events
and constantly meeting new people
i realized that i'm filming this in the
middle of a pandemic so we have to get a
little bit creative with the way that we
socialize but do
place more emphasis on this humans crave
connection we need it
this is often why these sites are so
addicting because we
think we have these connections with
people when a lot of times their
connections are really very superficial
so many times i've seen married couples
at restaurants each glued to their phone
and not ever really talking to each
other
or how many times have you seen either
parents or their kids
on their phone not really talking to
each other at a restaurant or how many
people actually
sit down and have dinner and shared
together laugh together
tell stories together at dinner time so
think of the people that you value in
your life and find ways to build a
deeper connection with them
tip number four is to try adopting new
hobbies or activities that bring you joy
sometimes the best way to beat an old
habit is by replacing it with a new one
i remember when my husband quit video
games it was very hard for him initially
but he used that extra time to spend
more quality time with my daughter and i
and get back to his old hobbies of
construction and building furniture
if you feel like you don't really have
hobbies or the hobbies you used to have
don't really bring you joy anymore it
could be several things
depression can definitely be a cause you
might not feel like you have the time or
the money to do so
or you might just not be trying new
things maybe try going to a place that
you've never
been to before try adopting a new hobby
or try meeting new people
our brains start aging the moment we
stop learning
trying new things and having new
experiences can help you develop more
creativity
and possibly give you the motivation you
need to take on new projects
tip number five look for ways to serve
others
i feel like this tip might sound cheesy
but looking back at my life the moments
when i felt the most empty inside
when i felt like i questioned what the
point of living even was
why i was even alive in the first place
was when i was more focused on myself
and what was wrong with me or what i was
missing and what i didn't have
but when i was finally able to shift my
focus to that outside myself and think
of
others and that other people are
suffering or going through worse
situations than i am
then it gave me a sense of purpose
because if i
get to complain that i'm bored about not
having social media then it means that i
have the time
to work on improving the lives of others
before i say this
let me be very clear i do not say this
to glorify myself but it is important
that i share it with you
before becoming a nurse i volunteered at
a homeless shelter i visited the sick i
remember
actually going to the hospital on
christmas day and visiting the people
who didn't have family members there
with them
i volunteered at hospital fundraisers i
volunteered at my church regularly
i did all of these things but they
brought me such
joy and satisfaction even though some
people would say it's a waste of time
because those moments when i got to
touch other people's lives
were the things that actually motivated
me gave me life and made me feel
that i had a purpose and sometimes the
hobbies that are meant to bring us joy
don't give us the same satisfaction the
sense of fulfillment and purpose
so if you are sitting at home bored
because you don't have these apps
anymore
i encourage you to get out of your
bubble and look for ways to serve in
your community
i assure you the satisfaction you would
get is much better than if you were to
just
stay on your sofa and do nothing tip
number six
practice more gratitude if you still
can't seem to find joy or fulfillment
from
spending more time with the ones that
you love serving others or trying
different hobbies
then maybe you could use a little more
gratitude in your life
this simple daily practice of listing
the things that you're grateful for can
help you become a more positive
individual
that sees opportunities rather than
problems
when you're grateful for the things that
you have you don't have time
to focus on the things that you don't
have or that you're missing out on
so focus on adding a little more
gratitude to your daily life
and lastly tip number seven constantly
feed yourself
stop i'm not talking about the
refrigerator i'm talking on a spiritual
and
intellectual level when i quit social
media i was so worried about what i was
going to do with my time without it
until i realized what i was doing was a
waste of time anyway
so i began to adopt more positive habits
instead and for me this included a lot
of spiritual growth as well
but i also did other things such as i
started to cook more and eat healthier
i started to exercise regularly which i
really need to get back to
i journaled i read i started listening
to more inspirational youtube videos i
was constantly
feeding my mind with positivity and
things that were going to help me become
better
each day i also made a conscious effort
to start
having a less association with the
negative nancies in my life
and start having more positive
relationships as well if you had a good
enough reason to stop social media in
the first place then don't just stop
there
let this one decision become a domino
effect of positive changes in your life
use this time to practice new habits
that will help you become a better
version of yourself tomorrow
than you are today and let me know in
the comments
what new habits you plan to adopt today
that's it for today guys if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
and subscribe so you won't miss when i
post a new video
i thank you so much for watching and as
always if you have any other ideas
please leave them in the comments i love
to learn from you
can't wait to hear from you bye